okay recording
yes okay welcome now to the computer
vision study group
um yeah once again i don't know it's a
fourth or fifth session
i did one a while back
now i'm doing one on the swin
transformer
um
with a subtitle hierarchical vision
transformer using shifted windows
it's quite an interesting paper that was
released last year middle of last year
and yeah it was quite success successful
and became state-of-the-art in different
tasks and
we have a look at it today
a bit in detail not all the details
because there are a lot of details
and
yeah if you have questions anytime just
ask them right away i would say you
don't have to wait until the end
yeah and
i had much fun
preparing the presentation
so for example um
this thing here
some animation
wait animation oh there's animation
because we're gonna do a bit of a super
mario style or maybe you saw my tweet i
called it super hagio style
and um yeah there's a little intro and i
prepared
um there's three slides i spent two
hours on them
and let's see so
level 1 the cnn
once upon a time there was a mario his
daily task was to look at images and
tell his yoshi what he sees on there
but one day a convolutional network
network came along and mario got much
better at his vision tasks
here comes the cnn
and mario crows
next level the two bit the vision
transformer
there they are mario and yoshi
life was great but after some time mario
natasha said yoshi looked different so
modern and fancy
mario was getting jealous
suddenly a transformer came along and
mario became all shiny and modern modern
himself
here comes transformer
mario shiny and modern now
i hope nintendo won't kill me for that
if that is on youtube
and level 3
is swin now
let's see there's mario in his fancy new
environment
however this new style was only a base
for many more enhancements to come for
example using shifted windows
spin for even better performance
and now here comes spin and ah
it's a mario tenuki
so in a way that's not really related to
our paper but as i said
i had this idea and just had to had to
do it
yeah that was the intro
now let's
do a little crossover
with the futurama
um
need a vision transformer why not
zoidberg
oh why not wit right so as
with or vanilla bit as it is referred to
was the first
really successful vision transformer
you can always ask okay why
why do we need anything else
than with
for our vision tasks
and although there are multiple reasons
so just name a few here
so in the vision transform and in
vanilla bit we have a fixed size of
image patches right that we use as
tokens that we give into the transformer
here
so they
they mostly are 16 by 16 pixels that's
what they use in their paper
and then they use these patches or
tokens to
compute global self-attentions on an
image
and that can actually lead to quite high
compute cost
if you um want to use a smaller patch
size so if for example use like four
times four patches or something right to
to capture more details you might want
to you know turn it down a bit but then
you have a huge
token
uh
length thing
uh sequence that's and the word for it
and yeah when you scale up the image it
will only get bigger and bigger so it
might in the end be quite a a big
yeah computational cost that you um
just get there
from trying to scale it up or trying to
get more details so that is
not good
and that's what the authors of the swin
paper as well
uh noticed and then they thought about
okay what can we do about it and they
came up with a spin transformer
which is calculating self-attention not
globally but in local windows
and the play applies patch merging
between stages
to get a more hierarchical structure
and similar to convolutional neural
networks
and um through the self-retention and
local windows mainly you get this linear
complexity opposed to a quadratic
complexity with regard to the image
patches in the vision transformer
vanilla vision transformer
so
over here in this in this graphic you
can basically see the
comparison right so there's three stages
in the vanilla bit it always stays the
same so it's always the 16 by 16
patches
and then it's a global
attention window basically
and in spin
you have yeah hierarchical
sizes of the patches so first you start
out by by four times four
pixel patches
and then you merge two by two to get
this eight by eight and then you get
sixteen by sixteen and you only
compute
the attention in these global windows so
basically these local windows so these
these red windows are where the self
attention gets computed in
and that is
more feasible actually especially for
bigger images i mean right right here
it's like four times four it's still
okay for the dried it's not that
uh costly but if you want to do some
more fancy stuff
it might get more costly so let's have a
closer look at this swim transformer
this is the architecture of the the
smallest
version basically so it's a the spin t
for tiny
and you can see we first have an image
height and width and
three channels and
then we do the patch partition
here they say okay let's do it
with four times four pixel patches
and then you get a 48 dimensions because
you have four times four times three
three for the channels
right so if you put it then you get a
linear embedding that you put it through
and then the spin transformer block so
they're basically two of them right here
right behind each other then
and then you get to the next stage where
you first do a patch merging which we
saw before
right then you get bigger patches
and again just transformer blocked and
patched merging so yeah
until the end really so it's
the architecture is not that
complicated from this high level view
and we can have a bit of a closer look
on the spin transformer block
in the next slide no first we will look
at the different versions
so yeah it's just really these four
versions um that were published in the
first paper it's been tiny when smalls
and big and spin large
and here you see the the number of uh
um
amounts of the blocks really that are
used right so you can see in spin tiny
it's two two six two
so it's always the number of transformer
blocks that are
chained together in each stage
and for the for the spin large you have
two to eighteen two
for all of them you have 2 to 18 too
you just have a different dimension
for the
feature
vector in the end
okay
now we get to the encoder block so on
the left side you see the swin encoder
block on the right side you see the
vanilla with encoder block and
actually for spin it it's two
blocks following each other
because that's
that's the graphic that was in the paper
and i i didn't want to create a new one
uh
so you can see it's really similar right
so first there's some some norm layer
norm then you do the attention
that's what's here here's a window moody
had self attention
attention that was useful
useful and then um you've got a residual
connection that is connected from the
start to the middle another residual
connection from the middle to the end
and the layer norm and the multi-layer
perceptron
yes so basically the encoder block is
you could say it's the same just that
the attention is computed differently
and
yep
on the next slide ah now we look at the
patch merging in a bit more detail i'm
sometimes surprised about my next slide
as well so i
maybe sometimes like oh yeah that's this
one um so let's assume we have an image
of a super mario of course
and the image has the size uh 32 times
32 pixels right
so
in the first layer
we get
our first stage
um we divide it in in four by four
pixels per patch
let's assume that is true here
it's not completely aligned
but
let's just imagine there are four pixels
here and four pixels there
so the per page that would be 16 pixels
and for the whole image that would be 64
patches
all right
second stage patch merging
of
2x2
gives us 8x8 pixels
per patch
and in total it would be 16 patches
64
pixels in each thing
and we just go on right so the next one
would be 16 by 16 pixels per patch and
it would be four patches
and in this example we end with like one
patch for the 32 2 by 32 pixels
so that's pretty
uh easy right i mean it's just merging
pixels together
in the stages
um but now let's look at the the window
attention actually because that's what
really is
the more interesting part in this paper
is the whole window attention thing and
how
that can help us in uh yeah
getting more efficient
and yeah also
gives us the ability
to
to look at
finer structures
so as i said we only calculate the
self-attentions in
local windows and it's important that
those are non-overlapping
so it's not like a sliding window a
sliding window usually is something like
like when you do convolution in cnn
right so you slide the windows some
pixels further and often they are
overlapping you can design them in a way
that they're not overlapping
but yeah often sliding windows are
overlapping and here we say okay we just
have these non overlapping fixed size
windows and this fixed size is also
important to make it
really visible for the
computation
so um yeah because with the fixed sizes
there's this linear complexity with
regard to the patch number
and
let's again look at an example so let's
say our
our fixed size
they always call it m in the paper is
four that means we have four times four
patches per window
okay that's four times four patches
and
remember each patch uh in here right now
is four four times four as well
so basically the length of it is 16
pixels
right so basically the 16 by 16 pixel
window but
in patches is four by four
and each of these patches
is then
put to this linear embedding so you get
a linear representation of each patch
and can then
compute self-attention inside this local
window
and that's what you do for the rest of
the image as well right so in the end
you get four
of those windows
they all have the same size because they
have the fixed size right so you always
really use the same size
and yeah then you compute the attention
now
one thing they noticed is that okay now
that we have all this attention computed
we have one problem
and that is uh we don't have relations
between the
windows actually so
for example like how's this patch here
related to this patch here
might be important in some ways
right um and
because they are computed individually
we can't tell from here though so they
say okay we do a shifted window
so what's a shifted window they just
move one of these windows
by half the size
right so it would be by by two patches
basically in x and y
um
now the example is here
so now you get this shifted windows um
yeah
they all
shifted around
and what can we see now okay before we
had four
self-attention windows let's count them
now
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
that's way more than before right so
suddenly we have
uh nine attention windows uh so
the naive approach would be to oh yeah
we just pat them
around here and then we mask them and
then yeah we get our attention but then
wait we have to compute self-attention
nine times now before we to only compute
four times
so um i mean one of the main goals
really of the paper is to to be more
feasible in computational resources than
than other transformers especially than
with and um because of that they say
like no we don't want to compute
self-attention nine times so they
do a little trick
which is called the cyclic shift
and the cyclic shift
is basically just shifting
parts of the image around right so we're
shifting some
windows so for example pixels
so we say okay we want to take one two
three four and seven these areas and we
shift them around in a way that we can
compute
a bit more
feasible
and
what becomes of it so it is again this
mask basically right that we had before
then they shifted and yeah that's how it
looks then right so we have one here
two three four seven
so what does that give us why do they do
it i mean there is still in a way
nine
uh
yeah
nine partitions right
but now you can see there's this
um
structure again that we saw before where
you have this these four big windows
actually
and what they do then is they compute
self-retention in those four windows and
they mask out
these areas so they basically through a
smart masking algorithm
that i won't explain in detail because
yeah there's one of those cds that would
probably take too long it's really
interesting you can check it out
yourself this whole masking but uh yeah
the explanation would take a bit of time
um
and yeah just through that actually they
they are more feasible
um yeah because i mean they could also
do to the
um padding and yeah with the padding and
the masking they could do it here right
but then or they could just say like oh
yeah we just put some
uh
something here in between and again we
have four
four big windows but then in each window
you would have to mask four patches
actually right so when you put like a
cross in the middle here you can imagine
there are four patches in each area
and then you have to do more masking
than in this case so in this case the
masking is let me count one two three
four five six seven
eight nine right
when you do it like this this naive
approach it would be four times four it
would be sixteen so
yeah so we have now nine masks against
16 masks
um
to imagine it better i put mario in
again and yeah you can see
the mario pixels were shifted around to
here
uh yeah and it's actually quite
interesting i thought like oh how did
they implement this it must have been
really crazy something
it's actually one function called in pi
torch there's a method called roll and
when this row method does exactly this
it rolls the
pixels
the way you want them
yeah
so
it's not that difficult to implement
uh yeah and this is how they actually
showed in the paper
and when i looked at it in the paper i
was like what what are they doing so
that's why i prepared this a little more
detailed explanation for you with
numbers and everything
yeah
let's see window partition the cyclic
shift as i showed you put it here and
they used mask moody had self-attention
and then they do a reverse cyclic shift
which i didn't show but yeah they just
reverse everything and put it back to
where it was before
okay let's go on
oh yeah
this one
this is one of the slides that i
prepared prepared last minute um it's
just about the relative position of
embedding
um
because when you know transformers you
know there is this positional embedding
that is used um to take in account
the the position actually of the tokens
or of the image patches right
that you have
and
um yeah they also use a relative
position embedding like the vanilla that
does
um with a
change that they actually
have a smaller bias matrix
than with so
uh
imagine in in the vanilla bit you have
like
yeah a big number of tokens
so these
positioner embeddings also have to cover
a wider range right because
yeah
the token length
or the the number of tokens in one
direction can be like a hundred
maybe and then you have to cover
yeah these hundred positions
in the local windows you don't have that
problem unless you use a really big
size of the local windows because in
local windows yeah the distances are way
smaller right even if you have a
window size of 16 that is already a big
window actually 16 patches so the range
only is 16 and not 100 but that's why
it's yeah easier
here to compute
the position embeddings
than for the vanilla bit for example
yes oh okay
that was an old animation okay that's it
but then
there was basically a level up
uh
spin version two which was released some
months after the initial spin paper
um it
didn't change the core function
functionality of spin so the shifting
windows and everything still stays the
same
but there were some some improvements
um you can see them here and so on the
left side there's a swin version one and
on the right side is spin version two
and everything
that's red
is new
so for example really easy thing to see
is that they they moved the layer norm
to not be before the attention but after
the attention post attention i think
they called it then right so here the
layer norm is after the attention not
before and after the mlp
and not before it anymore
um
yeah instead of the the usual
uh dot product for the self-retention
computation between the query and key
vectors they now use a cosine
computation
right with a gamma hyper parameter there
and
they also change their positional bias
thing so
yeah from this
standard
relative positional bias they did it a
bit more sophisticated
we will look into it a bit now but i
have to say
this whole spin version 2 thing i have
not looked at it in complete detail so
i'm not an expert
on
yeah on all these things they use here
if you have questions about it of course
we can talk about it
but
i might not be able to answer them
completely
but let's look at them
so
what was the problem they were trying to
tackle really with this layer norm
moving here right
oh they said okay in our experiments we
saw that
especially when we have
bigger images
the activation values in deeper layers
get really really big
so they
had a look like what can we do about it
how can we lower these activation values
because high activation values
are just not
good for training they they make it
harder to train the models right and
yeah big activation values are not good
we want to keep the iteration values
rather small to have a
easier training
so they came up with moving the layer
norm because i said ah one reason why
those values grow might be the residual
connection
because before we had this connection
let's look at it again we had this
connection especially this one from the
middle here right after the attention
right to the end so without this layer
norm in between and this
and also same for mlp basically because
you feed it and then you've got this
residual connection from the mlp output
and yeah so these
output values were not normed and then
the idea okay we move the layer norm and
maybe that helps and uh turned out it
helps
so that worked i will show you some
graph on that here
right so we have um comparison of this
so when it says s post that means it's
post uh
attention the layer name is post
attention and previous delay unknown pre
attention
and you can see that all these
triangular things are way
under the
the circular ones right so circular the
old versions the triangular things are
the new versions
and here you see the the magnitude of
the feature of orion's
and yeah higher is worse so this for
this big model the the huge model
actually it was really bad
before
they moved the leia norm but after they
moved the layer norm it was actually
really good it kept really low
so that is an interesting trick that is
quite easy to
implement and helps
um but they did a second one and this is
his co-nine attention cosine attention
cosine the tension
of course so they yeah instead of a dot
product as i said for the self-retention
they use this cosine
computation with this gamma as a
hyperparameter that you can set
and that is usually i think they say
around
0.01 or something and this also helps in
just keeping those values low
and
yeah
that's one of the things i can't tell
you much about in detail it might be
interesting to investigate
why exactly this
and
yeah
feel free to have a look at it
in more detail
uh and the next problem was the
pre-train on small as they wanted to
pre-train on small images and then fine
tune
with a higher scale right so
i mean it's again about this feasibility
and the ease of training
because
when you use smaller windows for
training or for big pre-training right
where you need the most load of images
it would be quite handy to be able to
train on small images
and then just do a fine tuning with a
smaller set of
yeah high resolution images
all right and they
said yeah that is possible with spin
already but
um then they see that the the quality
decreases
the bigger the images in the end used
for fine tuning the bigger the decrease
of accuracy is basically especially in
image classification they showed that
so their solution is something with a
really long name
um log space continuous relative
position bias
that is what
right what
so let's just look at it
and
yeah so they use a meta network actually
instead of just
this
matrix thing
a meta network is a two layer mlp that
generates
these positional bias
biases for arbitrary relative
coordinates
um
how that works
good question they don't go
go into detail on that really
um yeah it's probably something you can
discover when you train it yourself or
when you look at the whole
implementation or when you even
implement it yourself
um
it's also an interesting
thing to
to investigate
and they also say that they don't just
use the linear scale of the coordinates
so not like one two three four five but
they use the log space
because in log space
um
actually
it again saves a bit of computational
power
because the differences in the end are
not as big
um in total values right
because when you just count in integers
it's way bigger
than when you're in log space
so um i hope you can imagine that anyway
i didn't have much time to think about
this
before representation
but
there is this
nice visualizations in the paper
about just this
so here
we have um basically a window a local
window of size eight by eight
right
so we have a yeah eight by eight window
and then we have the like
the version one
position embeddings then
these um continuous positional biases
from the version two but in the linear
space and then in the log
space and yeah we can see that from the
version one that stuff is a
bit
diffusing and yeah just not as on point
really as those
new approaches they came up with
right
and when it's on higher resolutions it
even looks nicer
i believe those can be some really
trippy images
when you animate them
but
yeah it shows that just this continuous
positional biases um work way better and
way more on point than those
um yeah relative position embeddings
they used before
and that also shows in the
experiments
uh
do we have something about it
maybe yes maybe no
okay now let's first look at this
um because there are other optimization
optimizations that i won't go into
detail right now so they use
self-supervised pre-training for their
biggest models
um yeah actually the spin version too
they have one version that is the
they call it giant and that was actually
the biggest vision transformer
at this stage when they released it it
was three billion parameters and that's
where they used to self supervise speed
training
mostly
and then there is some some more names
just for you to check out if you want to
go into more detail on this is serial
redundancy optimizer activation
checkpointing and sequential
self-attention computation so those are
like uh yeah minor things they use that
help them
improve their their performance even
more
and yeah
so here's a little bit like how they
performed
on the imagenet 1k
classification
and you can see the twin version one up
here and the big and large models and
the swim version two big large and the
giant one here you see three billion
parameters right
uh and in between something like the
with g
and some others
and
yeah we can note that
this giant model is
the best actually
also better than the giant one
um with 84
top one accuracy here
on the imagenet
1k
v2 dataset
and
[Music]
we can also see that the the pre-trained
time right is for example
for most twin models way lower than for
the bit one
so that is in here they say tpu v3 core
days right that's the measurement tpu
three core days
so yeah i mean that's one of the main
criticisms for the bit paper is that
they just use you to use this amount of
uh
yeah
core days that no one can afford except
for
people working at google because 30 000
tpu v3 core days is just
very
expensive
so it's
it's better to have about 30 or 20 tpu
v3 core days
and you get
quite a good accuracy with that already
and also of course uh um yeah the
parameters
is
a better a better range than this giant
model for example
but they not only did classification
within the spin because it's a nice
thing about it you can also do
segmentation for example here's a
segmentation
benchmark the
ade 20k
they also show that at the point when
they published it they were the best
ones with their giant model
and
yeah also for object detection actually
um
which is here
oh
well in the in the end they show that
their giant model just beats everything
but then again it's it's a giant model
and yeah
it is quite big and can do a lot of
stuff
very well
okay ah again congratulations you made
it to the end
um i do have some code prepared actually
let me just quickly open that because
the swim transformer is available in the
hugging phase
transformers
library of course and it is the version
2 implementation so when you want to
have a look at some details like how are
they implemented in this or that way you
can just look into the face code there
you will see
most of it and can navigate through it
and see how that is implemented
and yeah i did a little notebook here
and just basically
one is just the example for the for the
classification to spin image
classification that is you can also find
it
oh yeah she had the wrong one wait
can i change that
okay i quickly stopped sharing then
share again wait a second
yes
no
okay great yeah so
it's visual studio code right um
so yeah the first thing really is just
the example you also find in in the docs
really so you can
just load some data set for example this
cat's image oh let's just quickly run it
right
import transformers torch dataset blah
blah blah load a data set get an image
just one of the cats for example i think
neos uses it quite often right
and then you can get um
the feature extractors of the auto
feature extractor actually so you just
pass in a model name
and here you have this
model from the hacking facehub from
microsoft so it's a spin tiny with a
patch size of four and a window size of
seven
on a pre-trained on an image size of 224
images that's how they label
oh that's how you can read those um yeah
model names
and then you can yeah
just
import it from pre-trained this win for
image classification model for example
the feature extractor is actually the
same that is used for the vanilla vision
transformer so it just reuses the one
and yeah so we loaded it
then yeah we have our inputs okay
feature extractor put the image in there
return tensors by torch
then do the model
get the logits from it
and then you can get the predicted label
right it says tabby tabby cat
i think it's about right
i'm not completely familiar with cat
races but
i think it's not completely off
yeah
i did a little example by myself then
because i wanted to see okay does it
work with other
data as well
and i had a look okay
what pre-trained models are there and i
found one that was pre-trained on the
euroset
data so satellite data actually
so let's load the data set
also uploaded by neil's here
then we just get some random sample this
time
this one here
and the class label which is pasteur
and now we're just doing the same as
before right so this time the model is
not from microsoft but some user called
gmo
and yeah the spin tiny patch for windows
7 224 fine tune heroes
basically the same as before but with
eurosite right so let's load it
from the hub
and then you can again
to inference and we get its pasture yeah
so it worked out quite fine
that is really simple to use really if
you want to use it like yeah
for classification
it is extremely simple
for segmentation
uh
i try to get it to work um but actually
i think you have to use a
a framework for segmentation so
basically the
the spin here is only the backbone right
you won't
get
the whole
pixel maps just from from the model but
you have to get uh yeah some framework
like mask rcnn or something and
plug the spin into it
as a backbone
and then you can get the segmentation as
well
uh yeah and i'm still working on on the
fine tune example
oh yeah i will share it in the in the
discord actually when i'm done with the
this one fine-tuning example
in hugging face space
so
yeah that's the under construction
but yeah now i'm really at the end
with my examples and everything
and
i think it's question time if you have
questions
feel free to ask them now
yes it's still running so
i got it
i hope it all worked and the sound is on
it and everything but um i think it
should be fine
okay great yes i said a lot of fun uh
during the presentation i i laughed a
lot and
uh yeah
sure
i think you have to stop [ __ ]
good question i haven't thought about it
i am just looking for the stylus within
paper wait a second
if anyone else has ideas
of course be free i'm just getting the
paper and then i share it
ah okay wait a second this one no
okay so are they more i don't know
so basically what is this diaspora doing
is it
can you quickly explain it
okay
and that is
somehow not working as well as with
resnet when you see
yeah no no it's totally fine just if you
think about it because yeah
so you think it doesn't just well it
doesn't cover the the oboe you say
global coherence as well as a
convolutional network like resonant
you see
which ones you want
on the very left i uh
that's true
yeah
yeah interesting um i would definitely
look at that because i haven't looked at
the stylus when i i didn't even know it
existed really so
yeah i
i think this this whole window thing i
mean
mainly because it it's similar to to
existing
convolutional networks right the whole
architecture and i think that's why
i guess most people
are able to deal with it easier or plug
it into to other
existing
frameworks and everything so that's
these windows are just yeah i don't know
similar to what revolution networks do
right
and
yeah long range transformers
i mean they're more more of a
transformer kind right
yeah
yeah i mean it's quite interesting to
see all kinds of approaches really right
in the papers it feels like there are so
many papers and so many things they're
trying out
um and you always wonder okay why are
they doing this and um we already have
that that one and it works well but then
other people want to try other things
and
um
there's so much so many papers um
also that built it up on the spin
transformer right and that somehow
changed it and
um i also saw the one about neighborhood
attention transformer
which has a
total different take on it again and
yeah
so
it's really why does any any network
exist right because people want to
publish papers and want to show off
okay any more questions
if not feel free to hang around in a
discord i guess i think there's mer's
part actually
to say uh we are still in the discord
channel i actually have to catch a train
but i'll be on my phone in the discord
channel
so yeah
feel free to ask if you didn't want to
ask in the background you can also
message me
um i plan on creating a notion notebook
actually where we finally can collect
our computer vision study group
resources
so that you can look it up as well um
yeah when i have created that one i will
also share it here in a discord
and then you can look at this awesome
presentation again
but you should look at it in animated
way actually
when you look at it in a non-animated
way it's just it looks horrible because
there are so many layers overlapping
so yeah
only animated
thank you for attending
and yeah
have a good day